[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
es un placer estar acá y agradezco la
invitación y vamos a hacer un cambio de
escala de tiempo entonces
como ustedes ven voy a referirme a dos
ejemplos de astronomía
uno de los cuales el primero que está
ahí es algo consolidado en chile ahora
qué
se inauguró hace no tantos años y que
está en pleno desarrollo productivo el
otro el segundo tema es algo para el
futuro pero que tiene la posibilidad
también de ser un gran desarrollo en
astronomía y chile en los área que ya
tenemos astronomía que tiene y tendrá lo
mayor observatorio en el mundo esperamos
que eso ocurra con esta nueva ventana
quiero detenerme un par es un minutito
para hablar de lo que una ventana del
universo qué significa eso en general
hay que tener presente que el universo
está a todas las distancias posibles
desde cerca cerca nosotros en el sistema
solar hasta el fondo visible posible en
universo el tamaño puede seguir siendo
mucho más grande
y lo que nos llega del universo son
cosas físicas son ondas
electromagnéticas son partículas con
massa son neutrinos ondas
gravitacionales de cuatro tipos de
señales que son procesos físicos todo
ello son unidades de energía es física
cuántica son ondas y partículas al mismo
tiempo lo cual tiene un montón de
implicaciones físicas digamos cualquiera
de estas no define una ventana en
particular las ondas electromagnéticas
constituyen la mayor parte de la
información que nosotros podemos
analizar no lo que recibimos porque ahí
recibimos muchos neutrinos ondas
gravitacionales que se presente y sacan
del pri manuel aller
a tres personas por la primera detección
de ella
pero que nosotros recibimos más
fácilmente y tenemos hemos desarrollado
en 200 años la capacidad de análisis de
onda electromagnética que además
constituyen un enorme rango de un
espectro de información que contiene
y aquí está el espectro de donde
electromagnética
concentrarnos en ella porque de ellas
vamos a hablar todo el tiempo y tenemos
un enorme espectro que incluye ondas
radiales e infrarrojas visible que unen
un área muy pequeñita ultravioleta rayos
x rayos gamma y allá mano izquierda
tengo lo que corresponde a los objetos
que producen estas ondas son objetos
fríos pronunciaron antes de radio
cálidas e infrarrojas las luminosas son
la luz visible que corresponden a miles
de grados las energéticas un tablet y
radio de x 8 electro que los conocen por
los problemas que tiene para la salud y
alta energía rayos gamma y acá están los
gráficos indicando longitudes de onda
la frecuencia y también abajo la
transparencia de la atmósfera que es muy
importante la transparencia la atmósfera
nos define estas ventanas en cierto modo
la parte blanca abajo son dos ventanas
amplia una en el rango visible y un
poquito de infrarrojo y la segunda más a
la izquierda en la que corresponde a la
radio onda y en esos dos rango sólo que
nosotros podemos tener instrumentos en
la tierra la información que está en las
señales está afectada por tres cosas 1
la producción
cual el proceso físico en el objeto que
emite que las emite cuál es la
característica característica física la
transmisión de la onda sea cercana o sea
a través de todo el universo y ahí hay
mucho efecto que la influyen y ese
efecto marca en esa señal y nosotros
podemos estudiarlo y finalmente la
recepción de un proceso físico donde en
un detector hay un proceso físico que
son distintos depende la onda y ahí
nosotros tenemos la señal final
las nuevas ventanas que implican
cualquiera de estas cosas
sean la transmisión sea en la recepción
y también la nueva tecnología que nos
permite ir mejorando la recepción la
producción de señales depende
básicamente de la temperatura de la
energía de las señales ahí arriba y un
espectro en el sentido que una señal
tiene muchas longitudes de onda una la
producción una emisión de una señal es
es algo que varía depende del proceso
físico cuando el proceso físico es
sencillo hay una temperatura única se
produce una señal como ese es ese
gráfico y que eso es la señal de
temperatura del universo completo que
hoy día de 27 grados kelvin entonces en
el origen eran como 3.000 grados cuando
el universo tenía trescientos mil años
de edad acá abajo tenemos el sol con una
temperatura superficial de 105 mil 600
grados más abajo el sol también pero
visto en rayos x donde la temperatura de
la corona son un par de millones de
grados
entonces los rayos de onda
electromagnética que nos llegan dependen
de la temperatura del objeto que la
produce
energía de esa producción ahora
la mayor parte energía de las señales se
produce por temperatura pero hay otros
fenómenos también más complicados y eso
nos va a interesar en lo que viene
la naturaleza de las señales que nos
permiten su interpretación de la
producción cuál es el proceso físico
como ejemplo sencillo la luz del sol
aquí está el espectro en sus colores que
ustedes ven todas estas rayas
cada raya tiene una información sobre el
elemento químico que la produce sobre el
ancho nos dice cuál es la presión que
hay la superficie del sol las
velocidades las capas del sol etcétera
etcétera un estudio de un espectro tiene
infinita información bueno si él es
conocido por ser el mayor centro de la
astronomía mundial en luz visible en la
astronomía normal y corriente son el
número uno del mundo tenemos los desde
los años 60 final 370 y tenemos todos
estos territorios incluyendo los dos
últimos que están en la lista de la
izquierda que son los proyectos que
vienen que están en construcción
así que no voy a referir de ellos pero
ahí están
no me quiero referir es el gran
observatorio que hay en chile hoy día en
operaciones quien mira el universo frío
y esa es la nueva ventana estamos viendo
cosas que no se veían antes ok
ahí se llama alma y vamos a hablar un
poquito de alma y nos permite ver el
polvo en la galaxia polvo que está a
unos pocos cientos de grados menos de
100 grados a un estudio de los sistemas
planetarios en otra estrella porque
tiene una gran sensibilidad y una gran
resolución y los sistemas planetarios en
su origen también son sistemas fríos el
nacimiento de otras galaxias a través
también del gas y polvo que la forma
tener distintas distancias está la
galaxia más antigua posible y la primera
época del universo cuando universo tenía
300 mil años que se separan a la luz de
la materia y la luz esa y se enfría
durante la expansión del universo por
por ciudad de 1800 millones de años
abajo hay un ejemplo de cosas por ser
bajas por almas recientemente
en este punto esta área
las ondas las ondas de radio tienen
distintas longitudes de onda si tienes
energía y aquí vamos a hablar de las
ondas milimétricas más corta el
precursor de alma es un telescopio en
eeuu se llama de ley que fue construido
en 1972 que un interferómetro que tiene
27 antenas a cierta frecuencia que
requiere ya comparado con los los
radiotelescopios más antiguos requiere
bajo por de agua en la atmósfera y
requiere una cierta altura entonces y en
esa época se eligió new méxico una
planicie a 2100 metros de altura el año
85 en el arroyo que el observatorio
nacional de radioastronomía eeuu nace el
proyecto que se enamora esta época
millimeter array e-mail quiere un
interferómetro igual que él vía ley pero
ahonda es mucho más corta
la frecuencia más alta por lo tanto en
europa japón también tienen proyectos
similares
y todo ello necesitan imperiosamente
bajar la cantidad de vapor de agua a la
atmósfera porque ahí es donde es
transparente sin vapor de agua y en el
año 91 93 en esos años europeos
japoneses vienen sitios el desierto de
atacama altura es más o menos 8.500 4000
metros a la altura de tan tal copiapó
1 supe de estas cosas porque estaba en
un comité de en europa en la eso donde
teníamos todo el informe y la gente
tenía muchos problemas uno por el costo
de esos lugares aislados lejos de todo
tipo de caminos y de ciudades y la gente
se burlaba particularmente recuerdos
japoneses sufría mucho con estas pugnas
a 4000 metros de altura la experiencia
previa previa que los astrónomos
teníamos era en mauna kea en hawai o
4200 metros de altura donde era muy
difícil trabajar y se pensaba que la
máxima altura posible yo trabajé muchas
veces ahí con mucha gente y siempre
teníamos el problema
ahora el año 94 principio de año me
contactaron desde el enero cuando yo
estaba en chile porque querían visitar
sitios posibles sitio en el cierto
atacama como yo sabía lo que querían es
el trabajo y compré las cartas de
instituto geográfico militar de toda la
zona y la busqué
con cuidado y encontré un solo lugar
posible
porque estaba una superficie muy amplia
unos veinte kilómetros para poder poner
las antenas pero estaba a cinco mil
5.000 metros de altura y bien pensaron
que no era posible trabajar a esa altura
bueno ese fue cuando vinieron fuimos a
este lugar por suerte y en el national
geographic a lanchas gráfico la revista
del año 2014 aparece un artículo donde
hay está descrito el el inicio de ese
viaje
es la planicie cantor aunque esta foto
tomada
en ese año digamos
hoy día en esta planicie hay 64 antenas
que forman el conjunto del territorio
alma y la inauguración fue en marzo del
y aquí nos juntamos cuatro de los
astrónomos que en esa época hicimos este
viaje digamos
el sitio de gente como ustedes de una
planicie con cerros ahí que está marcado
que todos tienen sobre cinco mil metros
de la planifica 5.500 metros y este un
lugar único realmente en el mundo entero
por ser plano con un clima que es
utilizable a 5000 metros de altura si
ustedes piensen en europa el monte
montblanc está a 4 mil 800 metros
siempre cubierto de nieve imposible 4
largo en asia ok
los montañas alrededor de everest son
todas más alta pero están cubiertas de
nieve y de nubes todo el tiempo en
cambio aquí las nubes son pocas
entonces alma constituye una ventana al
universo frío
chile tiene el mejor sitio del mundo
para esta astronomía
y eso ya ha reconocido mundialmente los
88 grupos de europeos japoneses todos se
unieron cuando vieron la calidad de este
sitio
el observatorio alma hoy día nuestra
torio realmente mundial donde participan
casi todos los países del mundo y además
en sus alrededores que son estos cerros
que están entre 5.000 y 6.000 metros hay
toda una variedad de nuevos
observatorios se van a construir otros
más
así que chile tiene algo muy especial el
segundo tema el otro extremo los rayos
gamma que son radio más energéticos de
la onda electromagnética y que no
en la visión de un universo violento y
energético
y
los rayos gamma no cruzan la atmósfera
están detenidos por la atmósfera y por
lo tanto se observan a través del
satélite y los satélites son caros y los
instrumentos pequeños
corresponden a fenómenos de muy alta
energía no necesariamente de pura
temperatura las temperaturas más alta el
universo ya no existen en el universo
actual salvo en el interior de las
estrellas más grandes pero en el
interior
pero si se producen fenómenos que tienen
que ver con altas energías cuando hay
choques de hoyos negros de estrellas de
neutrones etcétera que producen no
solamente esto sino que ondas
gravitacionales también aquí tenemos un
1 ese objeto aunque he visto en
distintas ondas que una una nebulosa una
nebulosa una explosión de supernova o
que hay ustedes ven que cada onda nos da
una imagen diferente complementaria
las ondas de radio gama nos van a
permitir analizar en detalle los núcleos
de galaxias los gobios negros y los
efectos que están alrededor de ellos que
se llaman plaza de hoy día que son los
más energéticos que hay digamos ahora
hay una posibilidad de observarlo a la
atmósfera
en la tierra porque los rayos gamma que
llegan se descomponen y dar una lluvia
de partículas secundarias y esas
partículas dan seis pasos de luz y eso
es un que es capaz de uno detectarlo y
si tiene una serie de telescopios puede
derivar cuál es la dirección y la
energía del cual viernes un rayo
y el proyecto esto se llama un proyecto
de efectos eren con una raíz de
telescopio y hay un nuevo proyecto
mundial que va a estar en chile hay uno
el inferior norte y uno de los elementos
urban ser 100 telescopio y van a estar
re ubicado a cerca de paranal en una
planicie de 2500 2.600 metros de altura
y este proyecto realmente es un proyecto
también mundial incluye 32 países 210
instituciones 1.300 astrónomos
representantes chilenos tenemos radiales
de la católica y van a ver estos dos
observatorios norte y sur y esto nos va
a permitir con tres tipos de telescopio
individuales de los cuales hay 100 que
va a estar en chile formar un stop a rey
y tener una gran resolución tener mayor
10 veces más capacidad de energía que
todo lo que existe crista ahora y va a
ver mucha tecnología nueva electrónica
fotomultiplicadores mucho rápido y uno
espera pasar de unas cientos de fuentes
que se conocen
distribuyen el universo de la cercana a
la más lejana a miles
y poder derivar exactamente cuál estos
procesos físicos en el interior de estos
objetos y cuáles son los lugares donde
las cosas son más energéticas y más
violentas más rápidas que hay entonces
así que este un gran salto y una nueva
ventana a futuro hoy día muchas gracias
[Aplausos]